- Sterling and I are
both super competitive.
We've figured this out,
which means we're also both passionate.
So that's what I call competitiveness,
- Yes ma'am.
- Passion, about the things
that we love most in life.
And some of those things
might be a little weird.
I've already warned him about one of my,
(audience laughing)
so it's time to come clean about our
♪ Obsessions ♪
- (audience clapping)
- Get it Jessie.
- [Sterling] Do it.
- That's right. It's time once
again, to own our obsessions,
I'll hit this button,
- Okay.
and a topic will be selected
by our super random supercomputer.
So let's go, Sterling's
obsessions are first.
Here's one of Sterling's
- Okay, let's see it.
♪ Obsessions ♪
(laughing)
- [Sterling] I hit the
button, who hits the button?
- I'll hit the button.
- You hit the button.
- I have so much power. (dinging)
- [Sterling] You do, (Kelly laughing)
- The whole show.
- Things just show up.
Okay, wait, this is.
- Ooh.
- What, this isn't like an obsession.
This is like a Tuesday night for me,
what are you talking about?
It's a cookie.
- All right, okay, listen,
It's specific to like...
there's ones that they
make at Trader Joe's.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- Y'all know, look sis,
You know what I'm talking
about. (audience clapping)
- Those are good, I do know.
- And I tried to call myself
having like a guilt free snack.
Cause they're vegan.
(audience laughing softly)
That don't really mean nothing.
That's so much sugar up in them
cookies, (audience laughing)
but like, I'm like,
I'll just have like two or three and I...
Brown will kill a bag,
- Oh.
like in a night.
And so that's the thing about
it is that I don't know how
to just have one of them,
- Yeah.
but they're so good.
And they're vegan and you
know I ain't eating eggs,
I ain't hurting nobody.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
And the thing about the oatmeal cookies,
a lot of people like oatmeal raisins.
I don't want no raisins up in my oatmeal.
The raisins get caught in my teeth.
and I don't like that whole thing,
but just give me some chocolate,
little salt and the oatmeal.
- Yeah, a little Himalayan
salt with that chocolate.
- Come on girl, a little pink,
- Oh my God.
- Little pink salt on that
joint? (audience clapping)
- Come on now.
- Yes, yes!
- I love it.
- That's my joint, thank you.
- Okay, wait, I'm next.
Here's one of my
- Let's do it.
♪ Obsessions ♪
I just want Jessie to do
it every time, you hit,
you can hit my button.
- Okay, I'm gonna hit your button.
- I don't know if that sound right
- No... (laughs loud) (dinging)
That's amazing.
Okay, wait.
Okay, here's the thing.
(Sterling laughs)
Here's the thing.
- The dust.
- I don't actually like
the chip of Doritos.
- You lick the chips?
- I just,
I just like the cheese,
and this is the weirdest
thing ever, I know,
but since childhood I'm
like the chips are kinda not
my favorite thing.
It's the dust on it.
And so I, if I ever have like,
you know, a little bag of it,
I'll lick them and then
I'll put them in the trash.
(audience laughing)
- You a chip licker.
- I'm a chip licker. (audience laughing)
- Wow!
- Here's the thing, I don't,
the chips, I don't, no offense.
I just, Doritos...
I just don't like
- It doesn't do it for you.
- A chip really in general.
- Right.
Chips aren't my thing,
but boy, I love that dusty.
- And you like the cheese, like are you...
- I'm a, I love cheese.
- Right. But not a ranch woman.
- No, not Cool Ranch.
No, no. I don't time for that.
I have a... No...
I just, and my friends are so grossed out.
I have to wait till I'm like alone.
Cause like people get grossed out.
- I love your obsession.
- I have a weird thing, it's
a weird thing from childhood.
- I love that you own it though.
Give it up for Kelly, don't shame her.
- Don't shame me.
- Don't shame her.
- You know what? Shame me.